When solving an inequality, I want to solve it just like an equation. I'm going
to clear factions, clear groupings, and then combine variables on both sides.
First, I'm going to distribute this negative 3. So, I have negative 3 times x
and negative 3 times 4. I'm going to combine like terms to get negative 10.
Next, I'm going to add 10 to both sides. Then, I can add x to both sides to
isolate my variable on one side of the inequality sign. So, I have negative 2x
is greater than or equal to 18. So, I'm left with positive x over here on the
left, and negative 9 on the right. I'm left with x is less than or equal to
negative 9. Remember, I divided by a negative value here, so I have to reverse
the inequality sign. Here's the number line solution, x less than negative 9,
and here's the interval notation.